from timcast.com James O'Keefe accused
of erratic Behavior by 16 project
Veritas employees James has become a
Power drunk Tyrant said one unnamed
employee in a letter submitted to the
organization's board nobody's buying it
uh I've got my sources and uh I'm not
buying it this is the letter that we
were able to obtain through uh let me
just say sources in New York media
apparently this had been circulating to
a certain degree and I want you to know
a few things one this letter is signed
by I believe was it 16 employees
accusing James O'Keefe of being a power
drunk Tyrant and he is exactly who he
pontificates on who should be exposing
now this letter includes very important
bits of information and context which
leads me to believe
I think there are people trying to oust
James O'Keefe not because of any of
these perceived grievances I think
they're trying to just remove him as an
element of project Veritas because I
mean he's the guy he is veritas
I would put it this way if you're an
organization with 65 employees and you
generate Millions Plus in in donor
Revenue
I imagine the board members are thinking
like hey the one problem we have in
terms of control of this money is James
O'Keefe he's an ideological figurehead
who believes in a mission and founded
this this happens with with big
companies all the time it's like in
Spider-Man remember when Willem Dafoe is
playing uh Harry Osborne and he's like
do you have any idea how much I've
sacrificed they're getting rid of them
you get rid of James O'Keefe from this
com from this organization and you are
free to use that money however you see
fit the problem is I don't think
anyone's going to support him now as we
mentioned they're saying that they were
bullied that he's a tyrant let me let me
read for you the top note because they
certainly had to include this it says
the opinions data shared and anecdotes
were compiled by one-third of the
project Veritas staff representing every
Department not all signed this letter
but all had compelling reason to
contribute some signatories have not
been the subject of abuse nor witnessed
any abuse but found the corroborated
Behavior troubling and were willing to
sign
that that means right there sounds like
a load of garbage to me so what did they
sign exactly so imagine this you work at
project Veritas
someone walks up to you and says we
think James O'Keefe is bad and he's done
these things will you sign a letter and
they say sure
next thing you know the board comes
together there's a viral Twitter thread
where one guy is saying uh reporting
according to his sources
one of the board members who
orchestrated this had a whole thing
scripted in ousting James O'Keefe so
I've reached out to James I've not heard
from him but uh admittedly look man you
know when I saw this and a few other
stories today I was like dude
this I got questions man it's it's
getting crazy right now okay so if first
of all if you sign your name to a paper
that's making a statement that's an
indication that you are making the
statement and if you didn't see the
things that you're signing on to that's
fraud or at least could be construed as
fraud so don't sign something that you
don't believe in I think that's what the
disclaimer's for though isn't it to make
sure that they to say look I I didn't
see this but there was a disclaimer
saying that I didn't see it well I think
that James is a bad person it it needs
to be more fleshed out than just an
introduction with like some of these
people like it needs to be on the
signatories you need to see who didn't
see it who is just following along and
signing for the fun or because they feel
like okay and who actually witnessed the
things that needs to be very implicit
and it's what it is is sign this if you
don't like him okay that's really what
isn't that the vibe that that you pick
up it's essentially it's like people
that have some kind of incentive to not
work for James O'Keefe whether it be
people that want control of project
Veritas like on the board or whatever if
he's inhibiting activities they want you
know because he is ideological which is
the point of project Veritas like the
whole point of it is he's ideological
and they're looking to you know uncover
bias and stuff
um so I I think that it's it's it seems
like it's all emotionally motivated uh
you know with people that have some kind
of uh you know some kind of benefit from
Jane from James who keep not running
project Veritas to play Devil's Advocate
uh on the side of the people that are
creating this letter because I love
James and his work is that maybe in the
last years stress has been getting to
James like I I feel like I can empathize
with what he's been going through the
last year like he I saw him tweet out
like I'm not suicidal by the way like
you don't tweet that out if you're not
stressed out like honestly no I don't I
don't buy it look at this I don't
believe this I literally don't believe
it I've had people saying like Tim must
be so stressed out and it's like dude
I'm I'm like people make up stories
about you man look at this democracy
Partners trial in public I was yelled at
in front of jurors because he was hungry
and then he took the eight-month
pregnant woman sandwich like come on man
like am I supposed to believe that James
O'Keefe like walked into an eight-month
pregnant almost like give me your
sandwich I'm hungry and snatched it from
her that that sounds like something
someone made up to make him sound bad
right because if I take something from
you it could be because I went over and
grabbed it out of your hand or it could
be because you offered it to me and then
I took it
sorry that I really don't think I don't
think that the person that's accusing
James I don't think they're saying that
the child gave him the sandwich I think
that either pregnant woman oh okay so
well I still I don't feel like she might
have been like hungry can I have that
and she's like okay maybe I'm wrong on
your on your suicide point I mean I'd
have to know the context but I know it's
a common thing like literally just I
started out from the beginning with the
yiki thing about the suicide so I don't
know the context in which he said it it
could have been like a snarky remark
with okay Chief with the kind of things
he covered he's obviously alluding like
hey if something happens to me it wasn't
me that's exactly it was like a tweet
yeah like he just said in a tweet like
this couple sentences elon's been doing
some similar things I'm sure he's under
an immense amount of stress right now I
I've talked about how people claimed I
went to their house in Boston and walked
in their house two in the morning and
turned the TV on and people tweet that
kind of stuff and they believe it I look
at this and I'm like James walked up to
a pregnant woman and stole her sandwich
that's the thing take is not steel she
might have asked her and she said yes
that's right not been happy about so so
so consider this too it may be that so
they're greatly exaggerating these
things look man I got I kind of feel
like
I'll put it this way I worked for
nonprofits
imagine you have an organization founded
by somebody else they're ideologically
driven we have a mission this is what
we're going to do and this is why we do
it and you're like I want five million
dollars in cash this organization's got
50 million bucks but James won't let me
pay myself we got to get rid of James
these are the kind of thing that happens
when these are the kind of things that
happen at big companies after a long
period of time they want to get rid of
the person in charge who's motivated by
a mission
there's a saying that um there a buddy
of mine was not was an entrepreneur said
some people are good at starting
companies and some people are good at
running companies some people are
founders some people are CEOs somebody
founds a company and then they hand it
off to the CEO the CEOs are very
different from the founders so my view
of this it's just my personal opinion
and my bias cause like when I I mean the
sandwich thing really is there and then
there's also some other there's
something else I want to show you if I
would let me first ask you guys this
when you think of project veritas who do
you think of James would keep hands down
yeah James O'Keefe is Project Veritas
that's not what they think they're
they're here's here's an image look at
this there is honestly no project
Veritas without us you know look
partially true this is our moment to
make history I hope James can realize
we're doing this out of love for the
mission yeah that's that's all that's
all created in their own head if when
they start saying that they're doing
things for out of love that are bad for
a person that's rationalizing doing
something they know is immoral and bad
so I'm I'm I think that Tim's right on I
think that they're they're motivated I
work pretty tough love oh no I was
thinking like this abruptly I don't know
I worked for several nonprofits all
right not in this context and here's
what happens because these organizations
don't function like the same kind of
companies people who work here work for
a mission they're not part of the reason
you get paid less when you work in a
nonprofit is because you're doing
something you want to do for a mission
and so at every single non-profit office
I worked these are all events
fundraising Street campusing Etc they
had a policy all of them to fire every
single person in the office the moment a
person starts expressing demoralization
I mean like morale
and so the fear was if somebody starts
getting upset
and feeling aggravated or aggrieved
they'll go to a person in another room
and go you know what's going on man I
don't like nothing what are you doing
I'm just I'm so sick of this man you
know James was talking to me and I'm
just tired of it man like you know what
I'm talking about right James you have
yeah you know I mean sometimes I know
what happens is the negativity and the
demoralization starts spreading from
person to person where they get angrier
and angrier then they all start going to
each other
this this has happened at every office
I've worked my argument's always been
you need to have a company-wide meeting
you need to have a pizza party you need
to make people feel good you can't just
fire everybody but this is what they do
they churn and burn they they just burn
through people
I'm wondering if a component of this is
somebody who wants James O'Keefe ousted
from the organization wants control of
the assets and resources is going around
telling people like yeah like that that
time he yelled at you remember and
they're like oh yeah and they took that
woman's sandwich yeah yeah he did do
that and then a week later they're like
remember when you told me you told me
that he yelled at you and took that
woman sandwich yeah we wrote that down
signed the paper and they go oh okay the
thing is once you make accusations
against people too regardless of what
the truth is and regardless of how easy
it is to disprove it they'll run with
that narrative so in New Hampshire for
example there was this uh Senate Senator
race going on there was uh don balduck
against Maggie Hassan and joa from
breaking the flaw who's a co-host on
free talk live with me he was at this
protest and he was definitely you know
being annoying and getting in people's
faces but he never touched anybody never
laid a hand on anyone and Don Baltic
basically just lied and said that he
attacked him and hit him and um you know
there was video footage of everything
that was going on and we released it
from the libertarian party in New
Hampshire showing that they never touch
each other at all or anything but it
just ran with it and then the Democrats
were picking it up too even though they
could use this as an attack against
baldick they knew that it you know it
would have been very easy to say like
look this guy isn't telling the truth
but just because a narrative was put out
there it's impossible to disprove it
even if you have all the video footage
and everything so well there's that's
because there's a there's a motivated
block of people to the motive a block of
people that are motivated to believe it
or it needs to spread it even if they
don't actually believe it pylon culture
yeah which is like it's it's a tough
justification to not utilize false
accusations against your enemy because
it's like they're your enemy and you
need to win if it's the combat State of
Mind conflict anything to get the job
done in those situations but when like
the culture when you're having
communication it's like I mean I know
that desire like I want this so bad that
I'm willing to accept falsehoods to get
it it's just not the right ethics I
think that's sloppy tactics though I
think that the move if you're smart you
sit back you value the battlefield you
wait you find something accurate
something that will literally pierce the
enemy's heart if you will and that's
what you go for like I mean obviously
maybe you can make disinformation or
work you for you sometimes but I think
in the long run it's a failing strategy
but sometimes it's just a really long
run if you wish it would go faster I'm
not so confident that it actually is a
failing strategy uh yeah I mean it All
is fair and Love and War is a phrase for
a reason uh underhanded tactics
frequently work even if they're under
underhanded and I think that you see
that in modern politics pretty clearly I
mean it's not it's not rare for a
politician to lie about their opponent
or to exaggerate or to pick up a
republican that attacks a republican
it's not unusual for a Democrat to pick
up the the attack if the person is
leading you know so I really do think
that the the all's fair and Love and War
thing is is predominant and yeah but at
least this particular issue but how do
people feel about the government right
now how do they feel about Congress you
know I mean that's my long it might be
it's a it's a kind of how much your time
preference how long are you willing to
look out in the future so here we are
now we're like the Congress is like it's
like lowest level ever but everyone
hates Congress for different reasons you
asked what you ask most people and they
are happy with their own Congress people
the people they don't like are the
Congress people that get in the way of
the policies that their congressperson
is looking to you know looking to push
forward after last night we did a show
at Congress and Lauren bobert's office I
gained a new love for those people and
that building and the the Congress
itself it felt very inviting like it it
it a lot of people really want to do
good and they have different tactics
There's real invitations really hard not
to make a January 6th joke it was
shocking how how at home I felt there
how like good it felt the people are
like at this level of what we talk about
on the show kind of like all of them are
at this I think then I guess there's a
lot of probably older Congress people
that aren't fired up and those people
are just like you know playing paying
the bill to get by I'm not as interested
in that mentality but the Young people
that want to provoke change and and stop
crazy change is like I'm all on board
with that so my my Congress approval
rating is up after yesterday personally
wow uh but I won't point out we're not
at War this is not a war so if people
are using false accusations to get James
ousted it's not war and all is not fair
in in legal battles so if they're doing
something underhanded I think that
that's going to get some people in a lot
of trouble thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time